Chevy Vortekch V8 bubble eye key fob
problems. You got a key fob that's not
programming properly. Here's how to do
it. You know, a lot of guys will have
troubles on these trucks not programming
the key fob. And I know why. Let's check
it out. Trust me, I'm a mechanic. All
right. Bubble eye Chevrolet. Oh yeah,
he's got a bunch of water in there. We
got to drill a little hole to get it to
drain. Look at all that water.
So, this is a 2001 and I've been
teasing, you know, showing some stuff on
this thing and it is nice, but he's got
a key fob. He can't program it right.
So, let's check it out. So, the standard
procedure is you put the key in there,
hold the lock, you know, and it should
cycle lock and unlock, but he's just
hearing the solenoid click. So, I got a
scan tool. You can do this through some
scan tools like the TEG 2 will do it.
But yeah, nothing's happening. And uh
guys keep telling me this. Yes, you just
heard it click. Nothing happened. Guys
keep telling me this. uh they do it.
Doesn't work. Doesn't work. Doesn't
work. I do believe on some of these
trucks, uh there was only a certain
amount of key fobs allowed to be synced.
You had to clear them out. So, let's try
this scan tool.
So, here it is. Full review coming soon.
Think car. This thing is nice, guys. I'm
telling you, I've been using this every
day now. And uh so, here it is. It's got
Bluetooth on the back. I'm going to have
him plug it up. We're going to see. I
already saw the procedure in here. Here.
Go ahead. Stick that in there. Bow OBD2.
Get it in there. Get this thing fixed.
It's hot out here.
So, let's turn it on. See what we got
going on in here.
So, I'll get to procedure and then I'll
show y'all. All right. So, it's under
body control module right here. Program
key fobs. Should work.
See how it does. I'll get the tech too
if it doesn't do it on this. All fobs
must be programmed at the same session.
Blah blah blah. Press and hold the lock
and unlock buttons at the same time.
When all key fobs are programmed, cycle
the ignition. All right. Hold the lock
and unlock.
The key fobs
start.
All right, I press start. Let's see if
it does it. You're holding them down.
You should hear it cycle. If that
battery is any good, we might have
checked battery. Replace the battery.
I've seen that before.
But yeah, it's doing its thing. Let's
see if it'll get it.
So, it wasn't working. That battery
wasn't any good. We got a new one. We're
popping it in there. I got me a value
pack right here. So, had to get that.
What is it? CR 2032. So, we're going to
restart the scan tool here. Should work.
So, these key fobs can be a real pain.
Sometimes it doesn't work. If it doesn't
work on this truck, I'll show y'all why.
But I'm going to do my best to get it
programmed.
All right, hold them down.
All right, so you're supposed to hold
unlock and then cycle it on, off, on,
off. Do it again, and then it should
click, but it doesn't work half the
time.
All right, look. Here's the deal. The
scan tool works great. The key fob works
great. Fresh battery. Can't program it.
Guys keep having this problem. You keep
telling me, "I can't program it. I can't
program it. I can't program it." No
matter what you do, you get in the
programming mode, doesn't work. So, this
truck is not going to be able to get
programmed without replacing the
wireless receiver module. and the
customer has refused that service. So,
I'm going to show you where it is. If
you got this problem, I would recommend
swapping out that module and then it
should program right away. So, on the
dash right here, the module sits right
up here and it is a pain to get to. It's
under all this plastic stuff and uh you
got to take all this stuff apart to get
in there and you know, guys don't want
to do it. It's not that expensive, but
it's such a pain because it's up under
there. And I have the exact same problem
on the Chevrolet Avalanche.
So the Chevrolet Avalanche has the same
exact problem. And we'll dig into it one
day. You know, I'll get it fixed. But
same problem up there in the dash. Let
me show y'all. It's got the same
problem. And I know it's that receiver
thing cuz you know, you can't program it
even with the Tech 2. Nothing
under here. I got half of mine to just
hit on it. Program. Program. Program.
But, uh, yeah, it's up under here. Pain
to get to. So, all right. So, the first
thing I want you to do if your key fob's
not working, get you some rubbing
alcohol and clean up all four of these
contacts and clean up these three
contacts right here. And then let it
dry. Uh, put your new battery in there
and it should work. If it doesn't work
at that point, you're going to have to
dig deeper and, you know, try some more
stuff first. But, you know, normally
these are just dirty from being in
pockets and purses and whatnot. they
don't make good electrical contact and
the buttons just don't work. So, the
buttons don't work and then guys think
their truck's broken and it's not. You
know, get you a new key fob or clean up
your old one first.
All right, so here's another tip real
quick. Um, you know, guys will try a
different key fob because if you look at
them, they're the same. Um, they've
talked about these FCC codes. Uh, you
know, it's not right for the truck to
make the model. You know, is there any
truth to that? I don't know. You know,
it's worth trying a different key fob if
it's not sinking. I'd do that before I
tore into the dash and, you know, got
the module out and did all that. I mean,
that's the one that came with the cat
eye. This was a replacement. Typically,
if they look the same, they are the
same. You know, they should work. I
mean, if it says it works for that year,
make, model, you know, uh, this FCC code
on the back, y'all let me know down
below if anybody said, "You know what? I
got a different one with a different
code and it actually worked without
having to replace the module." I'd like
to know myself, but as far as I know, if
they look the same, they should work the
same.
So, we've tried all these different key
fobs, new batteries. This one works on
the red uh cat eye. I'll show you that.
But, yeah, they work. You can't you
can't program them. It's impossible. The
code's not getting sent. The signal is
not getting sent from that module or
whatever it is. But, yeah, this one,
this one, I mean, you can get new ones.
This one works good. I know it works
good. Can't program it. Signal is not
coming out. and it worked flawlessly on
this uh bubble eye, but you know, that
module looks to be bad. So, it is what
it is. Scan tool worked good, though.
All right, so I'm in the '06 cat eye
right now. I'm going to show y'all
programming this thing easy. This one
will get programmed easy. You know, like
I said, um the newer trucks, you know,
to 2007,
I feel like they updated it. I don't
know. I hadn't taken many of the dashes
apart on these things, but I feel like
they updated um the key fob setup on
this. There's a lot less problems. It's
a lot more robust than the older trucks,
but I will tell you for a fact those
older trucks, the key fob does stop
working on them. I mean, we got two
sitting right here where it doesn't
work. So, let's show you how easy it is
to program it on those six.
All right, so check it out. Program all
key fobs. Program individual key fob.
We'll do that. Um, it's going to tell
you blah blah blah blah blah. You can
have like four of them. So, there's four
of them right there. Now, this happens
so fast on these. I'm actually going to
have to hold this down while I press
this. Going to be very difficult to do
on camera, but I'm going to do it.
And there we go. It's done. See? Just
like that. All right. So, there we go.
Programmed instantly. Just like that. No
problems at all. I'm telling y'all,
these newer cat eyes are easier to
program.
So, this is an ' 06, and that module
should be up under the dash under here.
Um, same as the 01, 02, Avalanche, but,
you know, we got it programmed and, uh,
yeah, it works great. I just get these
on Amazon, you know, brand new key fobs
and, uh, get them programmed easy.
See,
no problems on this truck. and it still
wouldn't program. So, if you want to
know the technical name for it, it's
called an RCDLR
module. It goes right under the dash on
all these trucks, but the '06 cat eye
doesn't seem to have any problems. I bet
you they updated it cuz I never had any
problems programming key fobs on these
trucks. It's only the older ones. So,
there you go. All right. So, that's it
for the video. You know, if you got a
problem, replace the module. I mean, it
should just work by holding down the
buttons. The problem is the heat gets to
it, probably breaks the solder points in
there. I'm about to take one apart when
I get out of the Avalanche and get it
fixed up. But this should help somebody
so that you know where the problem is
and you can get it fixed. I will check
you out on the next video. Don't forget
to drop me a huge thumbs up down below.
Don't forget to subscribe for more Chevy
truck tip videos in the future. Later.